first off out the gate this video is
brought to you by curiosity stream it's
a streaming service with documentaries
and here's a secret to quench the thirst
of curiosity stream and I'll tell you
how cool they are later on in the video
but for now let's reveal a movie that
I'm baffled didn't come out about eight
years ago but hey we have it now so here
we go
[Music]
Zombieland double tap so Zombieland
double tap is the clever title for
Zombieland - it's also one of Jesse
Eisenberg's rules double tap
in Zombieland - is ten years later for
us ten years later for them so they've
been together for ten years they've been
a family for ten years which means
they're close enough to win knowing each
other but still love each other but I
know each other zombies have kind of
started to evolve another tougher to
kill an Abigail breslin's character runs
off with this hippie musician so they're
basically trying to find her across
zombie land as you're very shaved away
gist of zombie land double tap and it's
like this if you enjoyed the first
zombie land
I think you'll enjoy zombie land double
time this movie is basically a bunch of
pit stops like I'll we're looking for
ever stopping here we get into some
trouble we stop there we get into some
trouble maybe we have some fun but we
also get into some trouble and you know
we're on the quest which everyone's
still got and everyone's still great in
this movie and they also have that a lot
more cred under their wings zombie land
came out it's like who's that Michael
Cera ish dude that's the chick from
super bad what do you Harrelson we know
now it's like list of Academy Award
nominees and Academy Award winner I just
got to say I appreciate Tallahassee in
this movie and the execution of him
because if I'm gonna make an assessment
or maybe a generalization Tallahassee
was a character in 2009 when zombie land
came out and most characters in this
situation was lucky I was a character
that acted that way 10 years ago most
writers are directors I feel like when
making the sequel it would start to
write certain phrases Tallahassee
actually does say in this movie like ah
those dick sucking zombies don't be such
a [ __ ] and they just hear the
Twitterverse like no not even gonna go
there and they wouldn't go there they
would change Tallahassee to conform to
the moral posturing of social media in
2019 but Tallahassee in this movie is
very consistent with how he was in 2009
so I appreciate the fact that
Tallahassee seems to be untouched by our
2019 world I personally feel that's
important for characters to have that
kind of consistency so I appreciate they
did that for him in fact it shows how
necessary he is there's a commune of
hippies with no weapons you probably
need a Tallahassee in your corner in the
zombie apocalypse
otherwise you're the first to die also
Zoe Deutsch I believe that's how you say
her last name is Deutsch right I'm [ __ ]
with last names point is she was awesome
see the trailers and you're like RI oh
so she plays the dumb blonde big deal
but she plays her so well and she's with
this crew of hardened individuals who
spent the last 10 years wiping out
monsters that used to be human beings
they're pretty callous she does not mix
with them like the ones she's gonna roll
with that dude no he does not have time
for that that character introduction in
the zombie land world that could have
fallen flat but it works and it has some
exciting action when it happens is that
mean it doesn't always happen but when
it does happen I was actually really
impressed with it's like yeah those are
some solid zombie kills I still find it
fun putting a zombie land double tap I
felt the flavor of what I like in the
original zombie land in this movie is it
as good as the first movie I don't think
so I haven't seen the first army land in
a very long time but I remember the
first Dombey land having better pacing
in it also yeah this movie probably
should have come out eight years ago
we're kind of at a point now where we're
like yeah zombies seen it when zombie
land one came out this zombie cult
following he was on the rise we did not
have a Walking Dead show we did not have
two Walking Dead shows we certainly
didn't have one of the Walking Dead
shows that people started to lose
interest in in 2009 we had no Walking
Dead shows around at all
zombie lain was this cool new take on
the zombie apocalypse it was dark comedy
it was humor but it had that that story
had that heart it had the family dynamic
I like that new perspective into the
zombie apocalypse now we've seen it all
so zombie land double tap it doesn't
offer anything new that's probably the
biggest thing working against it is that
it's just time however though it doesn't
feel new it does feel like zombie land
it did for me it gave me laughs it gave
me thrills it had heart it had that
family dynamic I thought everybody did a
great job in it it felt like a zombie
land sequel and I will say zombie land
double-tap was a good time no alcohol
required also this movie has one of the
best made credit scenes ever so stick
around for that as mentioned earlier
this video is brought to you by
curiosity stream curiosity stream is the
world's first subscription streaming
service offering thousands of
documentary videos like the older I get
the more I enjoy documentary videos I
don't know younger me couldn't have
called that but have a selection of
videos on the cosmos I appreciate that
couldn't find a documentary on the
zombie apocalypse since the zombie
apocalypse
hasn't happened yet
but I did find a selection of videos and
viruses in case you're curious as to how
this world might become a
post-apocalyptic zombie-infested
wasteland cross-promotion fulfilled so
click the link below to head over to
curiosity stream comm slash John's enter
promo code John's when signing up to get
your first 30 days of curiosity stream
so check it out enjoy thank you very
much to curiosity stream for sponsoring
this video
I appreciate it or is a zombie land
double tap have you seen it what do you
think about it or what's your favorite
zombie show movie series anything zombie
thing whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]